we've been talking a lot about the
unnecessary and how it kills
scripts and you said how 98 possibly
even 99 point
whatever five percent of scripts are
totally unreadable it has to do
with both storytelling and
scriptwriting craft because
a great story that is not stage worthy
doesn't work in theater they have this
term they say it's a great story
but it's not stage worthy yes it sounds
great around a campfire
but we can't perform it on stage in a
way that will grip an audience
so you can have the best story in the
world but if it's not
if it doesn't work dramatically then it
doesn't make a good script
and you can have phenomenal craft as a
dramatist but if your story
is poor then it's mere structure it's
just well-structured crap it doesn't do
you any good either
so a lot of stories fall
a lot of scripts that don't work fall
into those
two broad categories they hear that the
underlying story is weak or has been
done to death or any variations on why
the story itself doesn't work
or that the
structure of the story does not lend
itself
to being performed theatrically
as a film tv show or stage or even
dramatic content these days
and the unnecessary
is a big part of that because
the unnecessary crops up everywhere
it's the profusion of unnecessary detail
is always swirling around a story
it's it's a lot like
in at nasa they talk about
launch weight like a rocket
is engineered to
only lift a certain amount of weight of
payload
with the amount of rocket fuel that's on
board
and it's a it's an escalating problem
where if
the weight of the rocket if if what's
being
brought on the rocket gets heavier then
you need
more rocket fuel to hoist it which makes
the whole rocket heavier
so you need more rocket fuel it kind of
exponentially
so they're ruthless in terms of what
gets on that rocket ship
and so
because they have to have the launch
weight has to
be what they say it has to be because
it's been engineered
right down to the last liter of fuel
that's on board
so in the same way that part of
your storytelling person
is saying i need this to go in the
script two
it may sink it it may
just be too much for it part of what it
is
is that it has to do with the forward
progression of the story's action
and what the audience is actually seeing
there's a chain of events
that constitute a scene or a sequence or
an
act or the overall story
and that's what is necessary
to make that script work and
if you try to add something in that is
not necessary if you go off on a tangent
then you may
you can well lose the audience
lose the audience's um being on the edge
of their seat
if it if if you're following a chain of
action
each cause creates an expectation in the
audience of like okay so now what's that
going to cause
and then the effect of that happens
which causes the next effect
and so if you put a cause in motion
and the audience is on the edge of their
seat wanting to know what comes next
and you wander off on a tangent then the
audience is going no where's the thing
come on come on
and and it's it can become flat
dramatically or dead dramatically or you
just
lose the audience and and
if you lose the audience then the
dramatic power of the material
fades it's one of the things one of the
reasons why a script
doesn't work or why you know an actual
movie or tv show or stage play doesn't
work
so it has to do with
the stripped-down nature of dramatic
writing
it's a lot like dipping a fish in acid
and pulling out
just the bones that's the bones are what
make
the story work and
as i was i've known this before
but the the showrunner i was telling you
about said it well
she said once you strip the plot
down to its just
pure metal on metal bones
that gives you the flexibility
to do something creative with it to
to play around a bit because it's a very
tight rigorous structure
so you can you have room to layer in a
little color to let it breathe
to let it move it's like a jazz musician
where
you know we're going to play a b sharp d
so you know what you're doing but you
can still improvise around it
and kind of breathe life into it you're
still following the structure
but you all there's also room to
improvise because it's so stripped down
and that allows it to breathe so it's
not mechanical
or anything it's it's alive
and so it's not so much what's
unnecessary it's what's necessary
and if
you have if you're a good storyteller
and have great craft as a dramatist
then you know what's necessary to make
the story work dramatically
and that's what's important if you're a
rocket scientist
and you can't make the damn thing fly
then you don't know what's necessary
so there is really only what's necessary
everything else is unnecessary
some of those unnecessary things can be
little details that add flourish and
flavor
and color and breathe life into it
but most of it is distracting extra
stuff extra baggage
it's like handing a sprinter a backpack
with 40 pounds of books in it
it it will not work but that's what
people are often trying to do
because they either don't have the craft
to understand that which is necessary
to make the story of their grandmother's
escape from a concentration camp work
dramatically
because they're so attached to
everything that happens in the story
they want to put everything in but
they're
bringing their rock collection onto the
rockets it's about to take off
and no this was my grandmother's rock
collection and it has to come with me to
the moon and they're like
not in a trillion years are you getting
that pile of rocks
into this launch pad and so
that they're they're ruthless about what
gets on that rocket and not
and writers have to be the same thing
that's why they talk about kill your
darlings
that kind of thing it's once you
understand
the mechanics of what's necessary to
make your story work dramatically
then almost everything else is
unnecessary
and you're constantly combating it it
reminds me of a
an old uh
tom swift story from when i was a kid he
was an inventor
and he invented this device that
expelled water
so he could go to the bottom of the
ocean
and turn it on and he would make a
bubble the size of this room
and he was you know deep and he was on
the bottom
working and there was no water and it
literally
expelled the water in the same way that
expels the unnecessary
there is nothing unnecessary allowed in
because you're
rigorously saying what is the cause of
that it's like
say that your sister calls you up one
morning
wakes you up out of a dead sleep and
goes hey hey hey i just had this
crazy dream that you won the lottery and
i mean it was the most
realistic dream go buy a ticket and
you're like no i'm not sleeping no no
go buy a ticket right now you go buy the
ticket and you win
you're like whoa so the cause of you
buying that ticket is
she said you have to and
now the things that come before you
buying that ticket might be that
you get a parking ticket you buy a
coffee you get some cigarettes
all that stuff comes before you buying
the ticket but the cause of you buying
your ticket
is she demanded that you do so so
you're looking at the cause of an event
rather than what merely happened
before it and the things that merely
happened before it
may or may not make it into the script
but
only if they see
there's the overall story where the big
bones of the action
are set up first and then you figure out
the bones of the action required to make
it work at the act level so you layer in
a little bit more
but cause strict cause and effect so
nothing
you know so getting that parking ticket
may not be part of the chain of cause
and effect that
helped you get to the store and get the
ticket and then at the sequence level
you know maybe that parking ticket is
part of the chain of events that is
necessary
or it may not get in at the sea scene
level you're inventing a little more
but there's things that never get into
the story it's like when you make a suit
there's a pile of cloth left around it
on the floor at the end you got a suit
and there's a whole bunch of stuff that
didn't get into this suit
so it's about
that which is necessary and only that
which is necessary
and rigorously stripping out the
unnecessary
you